for the grace of God offers salvation to
all people
teaching us to live Godly life.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us and
to purify for himself a people
that are his very own.
Well, happy Sunday to you Church. It is good to
see you here. Welcome if you have not been here before
if I haven't met you yet, please come say hello. My name is John I
preach most of the time here. And so
I'd love to meet you. I'm so thankful though for Ryan last
week handling the words. So well, one of our elders we're
grateful for that. It's an honor for me to serve alongside Godly
Elders. Like we have who hold to the
trustworthy word. We spent the last two
days on a retreat together and it was a special time just to celebrate that
we're all looking forward to next Sunday
when we get to celebrate a little bit more as a church family at
3pm at our church family meeting. So make sure you're back
for that. It will be a sweet time there today though.
We're continuing our Series in Titus called his
very own.
And it's looking at how the gospel changes both our church,
but also our individual lives because
we are Gods Everything Changes.
And so go ahead and take your copy of God's word and turn to Titus with
me again. You can bookmark that for the
next few weeks Titus.
being chapter one
As you're turning there, you might wonder why I have a
weed here on my table.
It's not a decoration. We're not trying to Spruce things up around here. It's
it's an illustration because I want to tell you about what's
called the world series of weeds.
It is where agriculture students from the US and
Canadian universities compete to identify problems
in farm fields.
It's actually called the Collegiate weed science contest.
Which tests students' abilities to identify weeds and
the right chemical to kill them.
In fact, the president of the north central weed
science Society.
said this
students need to be able to recognize weeds when
they are tiny.
When they get big enough that anybody can recognize them it's too
late to do anything about them.
There was a similar contest going on in Crete
about 2,000 years ago.
But this one had much more serious.
and eternal ramifications
it was the challenge that the Apostle Paul gave to
his Protege Titus.
As Paul understood the back story of the culture
there and create and he was instructing Titus to
a point leaders who could teach God's word?
Yes, but they also if you remember from Titus 1:9
last week, they all so had to be able to
refute error.
They had to be able to recognize and deal with spiritual weeds.
in the church
now since this series is based around the idea that we are
God's very own.
How we're going to think about this today is is we
think about the church as God's Garden.
And we are his plants making up
that Garden.
well, since the garden is his
and since he says throughout scripture, that
weeds are bad.
Just like in your garden at home. We must get rid of
the weeds.
That's the point today get rid of the weeds. It's his his garden.
So we must get rid of
the weeds.
Now primarily, this is a call to church leadership because
we're coming right off the passage on elders and verses 5
through 9. We're coming right into this from there. But this
is also a call for all of us to be aware of
false teachings.
Why is that important?
Why was he saying that to them because it was
present it was there false teaching was there. We'll
see it.
In the Gospel of Jesus must be upheld defended.
That's why this is really important.
For the church, but also for you and me.
And so this passage will show us how Titus was to
identify false teachers in Crete.
But also what he was supposed to do with it.
What did they need to do about it?
And this will be instructive for us today as a church as
well.
So look at verses 10 through 16.
Titus 1
Starts with the word four which means it ties and links
back to what he just said. So that's why we tie this with verses 5
through 9 for there are many who are
insubordinate empty talkers and deceivers,
especially those of the circumcision party.
They must be silenced.
since they are upsetting whole families by teaching for
shameful gain what they ought not to teach
one of the cretans that someone from Crete a prophet
of their own said cretans are always
Liars evil beasts lazy gluttons.
And this testimony is true.
Therefore rebuke them sharply that they
may be sound in the faith not devoting themselves to
Jewish myths and the commands of people who turn away
from the truth.
To the pure all things are pure but to the defiled and
unbelieving. Nothing is pure.
Both their minds and their consciences are defiled.
They profess to know God, but they
deny him by their works.
They are detestable disobedient unfit for
any good work.
God help us with this passage.
We need you to show us what it
means for us today how you want to
take this scene and Crete
and and apply it to our lives our church
our society.
help us have
soft Hearts to receive what you would have us
receive convict us challenge us where we need it.
That we may be doers of the word not hearers only.
In Jesus name we pray.
amen
Okay. So here's the first question that comes from this passage who
are the weeds.
Like who was he talking about who are the weeds here?
We need to know right so you can check yourself.
But then also you can be aware and identify others.
Now, let me make an important distinction here before we get too far down the
road.
When I say weeds.
I'm not talking about unbelievers out in
the world.
Even as yes, we're supposed to avoid false beliefs
that come in from the outside will get to that but but we
are not charged with uprooting unbelievers out
there.
Nor are we charged with going on offense against
people who believe differently than we do out there.
That's not what we're talking about here. The way I'm using weeds today
is how the passage uses that concept.
Those who are within the church.
Who claim to be believers?
But are teaching falsehood?
People who claim to be Christians but teach completely contrary
to what God's word says.
So that's that's the context of weeds today. That's who
these people are.
Okay, but again, how do we know how do we know who they are?
Well notice if you were here last week, you can read ahead read
back up into the verses 5 through 9 ahead of
this. But but notice how these these weeds have
often very different often opposite characteristics
to what we saw about elders.
What Elders are supposed to be about in the church? That was
very positive.
Here we see weeds are insubordinate.
meaning willfully rebellious against Authority
Paul uses the phrase empty talkers
He looked that up in the original language. The word is actually windbags.
Like blowhards, you know, like he's got to be they're just speaking. Nothing
now doesn't mean they're in articulate because they're probably
really easy to listen to
like there's a reason people will actually pay attention to them these this
phrase. These words are are void of
any biblical content.
Any truth behind them?
It's what Paul references over in second Timothy 4:3 the
ear tickling that will happen where people will accumulate for
themselves teachers to suit their own passions.
Like what I want to hear tell me what I want to hear more about that.
Yes.
This is empty talk.
Even further he says these weeds are preaching a different gospel.
That's what he says. This circumcision party is in verse
10. He's he's so called judaizers.
Who are adding the law back onto
the gospel for salvation?
Essentially they were teaching that Christ's sacrifice was not enough.
You need to do this you need to do this you need to do this.
That Grace is not what saves you
it's Grace plus it's it's not only Grace.
It's a false gospel. But going on these false teachers. It says verse
11 had selfish motives.
They were looking for shameful gain.
Some of your translations might say filthy lucre.
It's the old King James would say that.
Now I want to clarify just because a pastor is paid does not
make them a false teacher because I'm out, right?
but but the reality is
in first Timothy 5 Paul says Christian workers
should be paid the difference is that
this group of people these weeds these
weedy teachers were seeking to
profit off of Ministry. They were only doing
it if you would pay them.
No, y'all pray for you. If you 20 bucks in my
pocket, you know, like that's what was happening here. They were just wanting more
and more and more for themselves. It was shameful gain.
off of the ministry
instead of being content with just benefiting people glorifying God.
Willing to do the ministry like we saw from from verse 7
above willing to do the ministry without even
getting paid.
like a proper Elder would
That's the difference.
So Paul was not holding back here.
He was clearly identifying these people but he he twists the
knife a little bit more in verse 12, and he references their own
poet to defend his argument.
Right. You see that look at verse 12. He says one of the cretans a
prophet of their own meaning one of
their own prophets from Crete said cretans are
always Liars evil beasts lazy
gluttons. One thing to be
known as right.
Yes with your own people are saying about you.
Now Paul was probably referring to it's kind of vague but probably epimenides
of Crete from about 600
years earlier from when this was in this
man was talking about the people from Crete.
Just kind of making a blanket generic statement.
Well, we see here that his ancient forecast came true.
because these false teachers
these cretan weeds were teaching a religious
lie.
And they were allowing uncontrolled sinful behavior
in the church.
They were what he says they were.
So Titus think about this Titus was a pastor ministering
in a very difficult Place, wasn't he?
Not only did he have pagans outside the church who were
believing mythologies like Zeus was born on
Crete and like that was part of their mythology, but
he also faced this false gospel
within the church.
But do we not see similar things happening even today?
And we have colts around our society. Of
course, that would be true here. But even many churches we see
drifting towards this.
see false teachers
pridefully drawing attention away from the gospel onto
themselves.
You see false teachers commanding one thing and
yet living out a whole opposite thing.
You see false teachers causing disputes on
purpose.
in the church
You see false teachers following their own lust and
sensuality and living out all of
these fantasies.
abusing people
living sinful lifestyle scripture says you will
know them by their fruits.
verse 16
they profess to know God, but they deny him
by their Works. They are detestable disobedient unfit for
any good works.
Now I get all week to study this stuff.
You're hearing it for the first time. But as I'm sitting here studying this all
week. I kept coming back to this question.
Like how does the church ever get there?
How do these people become leaders within the church like
you should be able to see that stuff. How does this
happen?
Well, here's the thing about it.
You might seem like these people be very obvious on the surface.
They can often hide for a long time and
unassuming places.
Remember when you took driver's ed?
One of the first things you're taught to do is to check your blind spot, right?
Because there's something there that there might be
something there. You can't see.
And if you don't look intentionally, you might
miss it.
We should do that in life, right?
We should do that in the church, too.
In fact, it's what first John 4:1 says says do
not believe every Spirit but test the spirits to
see whether they're from God.
For many false prophets have gone out into the world.
There's a lot of stuff that we need to be testing. Okay. So how do
we do that? If we're supposed to test how do we do that? Well, first and foremost
you do it the way acts 17 10 11
shows us.
That the church immediately sent Paul and Silas Away
by night to Berea and when they arrived they
went into the Jewish synagogue. Now, here's the verse 11
now these Jews in Berea were more noble than
those in thessalonica another city.
For these ones in Berea. They received the word
with all eagerness.
Examining the Scriptures Daily to see if
these things were so
So see that.
They were checking Paul.
Like the Apostle Paul they were checking in like let me
see what he said. Okay, I'm gonna check it here Rita. Yeah. Okay. That
makes sense. They were checking Paul. So hear me clearly hear me
say you ought to check me.
You want to check your CG leader? You
ought to check your Bible study leader. You want to check your Mentor. You
got to check everybody even in the church. You need to be aware.
According to God's word doesn't match.
and
you also ought to take to test any other
teacher you hear out there.
Because it's often very subtle.
Sounds decent.
smooth
give me a couple examples.
Like you hear someone teaching.
That your pit will lead to your promotion.
Your setback will lead to your setup.
Your breakdown will lead to your breakthrough man. That sounds
good. That preach is really well, right.
beware
Beware because that might have been true for Joseph in Genesis
50.
It wasn't true for Paul.
Because Paul his pit led to get in his head cut off, right
so it wasn't leaning his break now eventually we know
theologically after death. Yes, but but in life is
what that whole thing is talking about.
All that's just based on the flesh. Like I want things better for my life.
So, of course this is going to turn into something better. It's health and
wealth Prosperity Gospel or hear about this one.
someone might say
if God really loved you he would
give you.
fill in the blank
or if God really loved you. He surely wouldn't allow that
to happen in your life.
Like do you see like, where is that in
the Bible?
Where does that match up here? Right your conditioning
God that based on what you want or you prefer. That's
the way God works. You see how that that's backwards.
And we could go on and on and on with all kinds of
subtle Little Things.
And listen don't just assume because someone has a big church.
Because someone has a PHD behind their name or because
they have a huge social media following that they're trustworthy.
It's dangerous out there. You've got to test
it according to God's word.
That's why one of our values here is anchoring truth.
Where we prioritize God's word
in everything so we can learn it. We
can know it and we can know how to use
it.
Scripture calls. It's the sword of the spirit that this is a tool.
That God has given us in his armor. We
better know how to use it.
And so just like the weeds in your garden, they might begin small
begin subtle.
But ultimately false teachers will make themselves
evident by their words by their actions by
their selfish motives
when you look at someone's life and you see what seems
to be contrary to God's word for leaders, then
you should be aware that something may be off
there.
That's why we must learn to recognize weeds quickly rebuking those
who contradict sound Doctrine within the
church.
Now I know what some of you thinking right now.
It sounds pretty harsh.
You guys just going to become the theological gestapo and
start squashing everybody who disagrees with you or doesn't match your exact
theology.
remember
We're not talking about genuine believers. Who
are young in their faith?
Or who are merely misunderstanding something theologically.
Because all of us grow up like that.
Right first Thessalonians. 5:14 says we are to help the
weak and we are to be patient with them all.
It means we're to bring them up in their faith. We're
to help them grow up into maturity.
And if someone's a genuine believer, they'll receive that
correction. Well,
And they'll want to know more they'll want to grow up
in their faith. They'll want to understand better. That's that's part
of the holy spirit inside of you longing for growth that's going to
work and so hear me don't be afraid to
ask questions.
Don't hear this and say well, I can't be wrong. Don't
ask me don't be afraid to ask questions. Don't be
afraid to sit down with leaders study through God's
word. We are more than happy to walk through God's
word and how to understand it with anybody.
We don't want anyone to feel like they are
excluded because they don't know enough.
what we're talking about here in Titus 1
Is false teachers who know what
they're doing?
Who are unrepentant in it?
More or less they know exactly what they're doing yet.
They will not turn from it.
So we're not being too harsh here.
In this we're protecting the flock.
Because think about it that wolf in sheep's clothing is
not there just to hang out.
It's not there for the good of the Sheep.
That wolf in sheep's clothing is there to destroy a
sheep or the flock?
This is not too harsh. This is
part of the role of shepherds in
the church. It's to protect.
And we also should protect each other.
And so again, that's the second question. Why must we get rid of these weeds?
Why must we as verse 11 says
the word is actually muzzle them like a dog
close their mouth. Why must we silence muzzle
them? Why must we rebuke them sharply verse
13 says why is this so important?
Well just alluded to it what Paul says first is
that they will destroy people.
We must get rid of the weeds because they will destroy people.
Look again at verse 11. They must be silenced muzzled
since they are upsetting whole
families by teaching for shameful game what they
ought not to teach
So what they're doing is they're traveling around and they're trying to get
these little pockets of people within the church and they're
they're turning either some or all of a household to
wrong Doctrine or wrong behavior. And that
was thoroughly disrupting the unity of
not only the family but it was drifting over into the
unity of the church.
They were upsetting and destroying whole
families and it was catching unsuspecting
people within the church as well.
Some of you remember may remember back in 2002.
when an out of control barge ran into the bridge
columns holding up I-40 over, Arkansas River in Eastern,
Oklahoma
and as that bridge collapsed
the cars and trucks who were cresting the hill
on I-40 never even saw it coming.
and and they
they were dozens of lives permanently changed
because nobody even saw it
coming.
Listen, you must be aware of things when they're
going off track.
Either in Doctrine or relationships or
attitudes and we must
be prepared to correct it openly.
If we don't things will begin to fall apart and people
will be hurt.
Our pastor in seminary used to say it
this way if you don't take out the trash every
day, eventually it will take you out.
If we can't get off track so first it will
destroy people if we allow weeds to flour a
second we get rid of the weeds because they dilute the church.
They dilute the church.
Verse 10 shows us apparently in Crete there were many who opposed
the sound doctrine of the Gospel that
Paul entitus were teaching.
That word sound in verse 10 is a medical term implying
health.
And so he's saying that that the the sound Doctrine
was a healthy interpretation of
the Gospel that Paul and Titus were proclaiming in Crete in
contrast though. Paul describes the
false teachers impure sick teachings
that they're portraying.
He says in verse 14 they devoted themselves to Jewish myths.
Which was an inordinate focus on Old Testament genealogies
and ritual purity.
He also says they command they devoted themselves to the commands of
men.
Again, things are added on top of God's revelation.
Which is something that Isaiah predicted back in Isaiah 29:13
these people draw near with their mouth and
honor me with their lips, but their hearts are far
from me and their fear of me as a commandment taught
by men.
Something Jesus reiterated in Mark 7:7 he said in vain
do they worship me teaching as doctrines the
Commandments of men.
What he's referring to there probably is the talmud.
Which were the 613 additional commands the
Jews instilled around the law had enough
commands in it. It was only adding the burdens on
top for people to carry it and they were using it inappropriately to
make sure that people felt like they
needed to do more.
And that was a problem.
Because the gospel is good news that
proclaims salvation by grace.
Not through following rules, not through following regulations. And
so they're teaching a different gospel.
than the one that they
heard originally
That's why for us as a church. We are anchored to
sound Biblical teaching to the gospel.
We're anchored to it as a
church, but it also hear me must be true for you as an individual.
The only way that you will know falsehood in your life is
by knowing God's word itself.
And knowing God's word yourself.
That's why you must dive in you must study. If
you need help with that will help you please ask but even
more than Coca Cola you got to know the real thing, baby.
Right, you got to know like that's how that's how they figure out
false money like counterfeit money. Right you you know the
real thing so well that you know, when there's a false
Bill circulating around right? Like you can
see this so much, you know, it's so deeply you can
immediately recognize when there's a fake.
That's the point of what he's saying here.
It dilutes the church. So we've got to know the truth
so we can hear and know when things are off.
But there's one more reason.
To get rid of these weeds.
From God's Garden. It's because they prove themselves not to
be Believers at all. They deceive themselves.
Get rid of the weeds because they deceive themselves that
they're even believers.
You see it in verses 15 and 16 again right to the
pure all things are pure meaning to the the Believers have been washed
all things are pure but to the defiled and unbelieving nothing
is pure.
Both their minds and their consciences are defiled. They're
still dirty.
They profess to know God, but they deny him by
their works.
They're detestable disobedient unfit for any
good work.
Paul's again referencing Mark 7 Jesus talking about a ceremonial
purification for a Jew and
and washing hands and all the things that they would do with
that. But in that passage Jesus teaches that it is actually
the heart that makes you unclean
Not what comes from the outside it's what comes
from the inside. That means you can wash your
body all you want. You can do all the rituals all you want. But
what you need is to be cleansed From the Inside Out you
need to be made pure you need to be made undefiled as
he just said here.
Something you cannot do on your own.
That's why the person who is seeking Purity before God by
obeying a list of man's rules turns
out not to be one of God's people at all.
Turns out to be an unbeliever.
That's what he says here.
If you're trying to do these things and saying your believer, it's not there because
this this verse 16 actually becomes the
hinge point of the entire letter here.
Where it it summarizes how
these unbelievers are living.
That their counterfeit they're worthless and it's the pivot
because from this point forward the rest of the letter will
reveal. What being God's possession
actually does in someone's life.
All of chapter 2 chapter 3 will show us
if you are his own this is
what it looks like.
It's the lifestyle that chapter 2 verse 1 says
Accords with sound Doctrine.
Like you teach the the healthy interpretation the
pure scripture. This is what lifestyle would
produce from that.
Because hear me again.
Merely claiming you're a Christian is not enough.
Our Lives must give evidence
of faith
evidence that the gospel has changed us from the
inside out toward obedience.
I'm not telling you anything scripture doesn't say first John 2:4
says whoever says I know him.
But does not keep his Commandments is a
liar.
And the truth is not in him.
Part of the deal. This is what it means. It's been said this way. There are
thousands of people who are experts on Christianity who
never seemed to practice it.
Now here's here's the caution as I say all of that.
Seen in so many lives even my own life. I've seen this.
the danger in this moment
when we say things like well, it's about a lifestyle
in responsible when we say things like that. It's it's really easy in this
time to downshift From Grace into legalism.
Where you walk away from this?
Feeling like you have to try harder.
You've got to be better.
So that God will love you.
Man, I'm blowing in I'm messing up. God doesn't love me.
And you hear this you kind of feel this subtle
like Challenge and go do more and be better in front of that. So
the lord loves you, but you already know you can't.
Necessary discouraged already and you're walking away think well,
I guess God's Never Gonna Love Me.
That's why we cannot forget that the
good works. We're talking about here. The lifestyle we're
talking about here is a response to
Salvation.
That the good works of Our Lives depend on God's
work in us his power in
US. It depends on Christ's finished
work for us.
We're not saying anything about earning it. We are talking about
responding to it.
Now we'll be perfect in that response. No.
But True Believers
Will seek to live in obedience
and Purity and they'll walk
in Repentance when they fail at it.
A few years ago if you were planning to vacation in Zambia.
You had to be aware of the street corner Emerald vendors.
And if you were driving in Zambia, you had to be
prepared for some confusion in the streets owing to
stolen traffic lights.
Surprisingly the two problems were related.
The traffic light thieves were selling
green glass chips to unsuspecting
tourists who thought they were getting
Bargain Basement emeralds.
Listen, there are a lot of Bargain Basement
gospels floating around out there.
other falsehoods
just being peddled like it's
nothing
even on the bookshelves in our houses.
And on our Instagram feeds every day.
Scripture teaches you might have heard of this before scripture
teaches that many cowbirds.
Will rise up in the future and try to
push out the gospel egg from the church's nest
and replace it with their egg full of
lies.
heard those birds that do that
Right, they they take somebody else's nest with a good egg in it.
They shove it out of there and they put their own egg in it. They just don't want to build a nest.
That's what is happening all over and it's only
going to happen more. So as we go forward, that's why we must
learn to recognize what the weeds are when they're tiny.
You must choose to listen to people who
are putting you in positions to
hear and be pointed to the Gospel of Jesus Christ his
life death and Resurrection in your place. If it
doesn't have that don't listen to it.
And we must have the courage to firmly deal with false teachings
both as a church, but also you and
your own life to say no. I'm not going to listen to that anymore.
And that's for the sake of the gospel for the health of the church primarily. Yes
as we confront, but there's a side benefit here.
We're about that first and foremost. There's a side benefit though verse
13 says there is a chance that these false teachers
might actually be restored to spiritual health.
As they are confronted.
even they
might be brought to repentance.
Teaching falsehood teaching false gospels.
They might even be brought to
prevents. That's how powerful this true gospel actually
is. See God can take any of us
right where we are and lead us to eternal
life when we repent and believe in Jesus Christ.
Whether that's from you teaching false gospels
or whether that's you and your secret addiction or whether
that's you in whatever you have if we turn
away from that and we turn to him
in faith.
He redeems us.
That's what he does for you believer.
rejoice in that
but also see the offer that's what he can do
for you, unbeliever.
May the Lord do more of that in us and through us this year
than ever before.